all right we're now live thank you
good morning and welcome everybody to
the uh november public engagement board
um
freeman's absence i hope that's okay
with everybody
i think people might know i'm george
devlin i'm from trafford community
collective
uh
do we have any apologies just that
apologies have been received from
councillor freeman councillor acton and
from andrew latham of council of health
thank you
and is there any declarations of
interest
no
thanks uh next item's the minutes of the
last meeting i'm assuming everybody's
had an opportunity to
look at them and
agree that an accurate record was the
meeting
yeah
okay thank you um so item for that
update on the current covert situation
in trafford helen if you want to
give us the update that'd be great
thanks chair so um
an interesting week in terms of
statistics and figures so we are kind of
i think this is a reflection of smaller
numbers than where we were four weeks
ago but it is quite volatile when we
look at our rates so today our rate is
378 per 100 000
um and that's up to the 12th of november
so for the week before it was 370.
so you can see that it does fluctuate
day after day so we're just really
monitoring that and it is looking like
it's plateauing
but um the interesting bit really is
that trafford remains near the top
for greater manchester
um so we're just trying to develop a
stronger understanding as to what is
happening really with with figures in
that information and however um what we
are
assured by is that our rates for over
60s are still low and are declining
which is really reassuring
so that's at 174 per 100 000. the week
before it was at 216 so this is really
good news
um
and for our over 75s in particular the
rate is very low so i think that's a
really good reflection of all the hard
work that's going on across trafford and
across our care system to protect our
vulnerable elderly people
um our testing rate is decreasing and
our positivity rate is decreasing also
so as of this morning we were fourth in
greater manchester but there's there's
not a huge
amount of um rates between us and the
top
um but just to recognize so when you
look at the figures that are published
in the men for example they are
published at four o'clock in the
afternoon so theirs will be slightly
different than ours because we go we do
our analysis in the morning compared to
them doing it in the afternoon so that's
just to make you aware
in terms of where we're seeing the
highest rates again it's really spread
across trafford so our award with the
highest rate at the moment is hail
central in the south
followed by stratford in the north and
they're both very different kind of
demographics and very different
geographies so again an interesting kind
of statistic there and then we have
ernst and timperley so they're spread
very much across the different
localities of trafford in terms of rates
our rates now are the highest in our 30
to 44 year olds followed by our zero to
14s our assumption there is um
that
a lot of the 30 to 44 years will be
parents of the the initial kind of
cohort that we saw a couple of weeks ago
of children but also that cohort will be
the ones who are out and about out at
work and travelling
you know that they have far more contact
with people
and than other age groups so that's
that's our understanding there
in terms of our communities of interest
in our being
communities um our highest rates are
within our asian and asian british group
um in terms of deaths and hospital
activity so although our deaths have
decreased but this is this is with a
really strong message of caution very
small numbers in terms of decrease so we
have fortunately a very small number of
people who pass away due to covert and
trafford and they have to
decline decline very very you know very
small numbers
there are still um people who are dying
from covert your residence in trafford
so you know that's the message we need
to stick by you know rather than looking
at this very small change in trend
equally hospital activity is an area of
concern we heard from colleagues from
mft last week around the pressures that
are building for our nhs system at the
moment and that's equally due to covert
activity people being admitted for covid
but also all the other issues that um
a pandemic brings so the general ill
health and population need
so um there are two very strong messages
that i think we need to start to
continue to discuss
in terms of vaccination um 80 of our
population have had one vaccination and
74 have had both vaccinations
for our 12 to 15 year olds 34 of the
school roll
so of our 12 to 15 year olds who go to
school and attend the trafford school
have had um the vaccination and that's
23 of the residents of that age group
so we are doing very well still lots of
work to do lots of encouragement of this
age group to be vaccinated and we know
now that there's a school offer and
parents can also book to take children
out of school as well for the vaccine
and we are
the area of concern i guess with the
vaccination is that our under 40s still
have the lowest rate
so if you are lucky enough to still be
under 40 or um you have lots of friends
and family members or work or
you know if you could take that message
back around the importance of getting
the vaccine and jill is going to talk to
us about the booster vaccine which
obviously has been announced for our
over 40s
from this week as well
we are managing outbreaks still as a
team and kirsty will talk to you about
that so we've had um
a number of outbreaks last week
that the team team's managing and doing
a really good job with
but um
i guess the message really is that we
have continued with our enhanced
measures to schools so that is face
coverings on the move so that's for
pupils and staff at high schools and for
primary schools um
it's for staff and parents
so parents that drop off and pick up or
if they are visiting within school to be
wearing a face covering and that's also
the same message for your early years
we'll also continue with the messaging
around lfd testing if you're a household
contact
and general covered safe behaviors as
well
for care homes
again we've continued with our enhanced
measures which will be reviewed on the
29th for care homes that is about a
pause in indoor visiting for 16 year
olds and under so this isn't about pause
for all visiting it's just for that and
that cohort of 16 and under
um
and uh but their cur their visits can
continue if it's end of life care or if
they can happen outdoors or in a covered
safe environment and that's really
important that we um continue to support
our care homes to protect their
residents
we are though obviously very much taking
into account that we're heading to the
christmas period and grandparents and
aunties and uncles will be very keen to
see their younger relatives
um during this period so our care home
um
commissioners and our infection and
prevention and control team will be
working with care homes to ensure that
families can have as close to a normal
christmas as possible that is safe as
well so they're the two things we really
need to be thinking about
so um
jill will talk to you about boat
boosters curse your touch on outbreaks
we've got an update from our community
engagement team who are continuing to do
some really strong work out in our
community
and um
i suppose the message from the from our
team really is just to continue
with the strong messaging around covered
security social distancing face covering
symptom awareness testing and ultimately
vaccination
but that's the update from us today
thanks chair
thanks helen that's really helpful and
really thorough um
obviously good to see that the rates are
continuing to fall
but obviously the key messages ask them
to be cautious and still to be aware of
the impact that covert could have
um is there any questions anybody or any
clarification anybody would like
no
so jill would you like to give the
update oh sorry sorry excuse me
judith chancellor
yes sorry
um just helen you know um
one of the things that young people do
is actually travel
by bus um
to and from school
and it
is an observation and whether it could
be um
that the
the children have to wear masks in
school the older children um
when they're moving about
which is fine and that's great but
actually when they get on the bus the
mask is underneath them and they're not
wearing it so could something be done
about that because actually it's older
people and younger people who tend to
use the buses more and the other thing
is the buses are absolutely crowded when
the
young people come out of school
thank you
thanks
uh council lloyd that we did write to
tftm to to request support and they have
been really supportive um i think it's
probably thinking about messaging
um
and modeling isn't it really
but we'll take that thought away as a
team and look at what we can do to kind
of um escalate that that message really
okay thank you
thank you thanks for that thanks helen
um julia would you before you go before
we move to the ten point plan would you
like to give us an update on the
boosters
thank you chair yes so um
just to a report that
we have now vaccinated 66
of the eligible population
of residents with their booster jab
we see this as a really important
program alongside the flu vaccination
program in people um preparing for the
winter season um and boosting um their
immunity uh for for winter obviously
welcome the extension of that program to
those aged 40
to 49
i think the other development in the
rollout of the
covid vaccination program has been
the requirement for nhs staff who are
frontline staff um to be fully
vaccinated by the spring and that brings
that workforce in line with the um
similar requirements that are now in
place for frontline staff working in our
care homes
and
in terms of that booster rollout
we are seeing a similar
social gradient in the uptake of the
booster vaccines and so somewhat higher
in our more affluent areas
and lower in the more deprived
neighborhoods um we're not surprised to
see that we've seen that across
the program as each cohort rolls out but
that's still no reason uh to be
accepting or complacent of that and
therefore we're working really closely
with the community engagement team with
comms and marketing um and with the ccg
uh to ensure that we have um programs to
promote uptake uh in our areas where
uptake is lowest and that we have access
to clinics in those areas and i know
rebecca is also on on the call so i
don't know if rebecca has anything you
wanted to add in terms of update on
vaccinations from from your perspective
um thank you
yes i'll do my update now since we're on
vaccinations so um i think most of the
areas i wanted to mention have been
covered by colleagues so thank you for
that um just to say that a couple of
things really um thank you to the feed
thank you for the feedback last time i
attended about the um the third dose um
the third booster dose and the fact that
it's visor and that there is no choice
there is now a message on our website
which um explains that in the kind of
simple language that was requested and i
will just check with our comms team
whether that's gone out any further but
that was that was an action taken from
last time so again thank you for the
feedback
um and secondly just to update in terms
of the booster
um i updated last time around the
ambition to have offered the booster
dose to all um nursing and residential
homes staff and residents which was
completed there is now an aspiration to
do the same for all our working age
adult homes so that includes many of our
mental health and learning disability
homes um in trafford with a plan to have
all of those staff residents offered the
vaccine before the booster vaccine
before the 1st of december and so we're
just working on that at the moment and
that's probably it in terms of my update
okay thanks rebecca thank you sheila
any questions on the vaccine update and
then on the boosters
updates
no
uh counselor welton no
i um just uh in terms of the
vaccinations for the 40
40 to 50 year old um bracket is that is
that program started now or is that um
is that going to be starting in the next
few weeks
um starting imminently we are just
awaiting the um every time uh the cohort
is extended we receive new protocols to
work to for the providers to work to and
um patient specific directions so we're
just awaiting that documentation uh
which we're expecting this week so
imminently but not quite yet
is that going to be done mostly by gp
appointments or is it kind of like a
walk-in
it will be
like the other cohorts so i think there
will be two access points so eligible
people will be invited through the
national booking system and the text
message and invited to go on to that
national booking line or call the
national booking line
with the range of um appointments
available but just today we've been
asked to confirm with all of our pcn
sites that they will also be opting into
that um
over 40 programmer we're expecting them
all to opt in so they will also be um
invited and recognized by their gp so
it's it's continuing with the same
access right thank you okay thank you
thank you thanks rebecca um
so moving on to mass testing ben
thanks very much chair so a couple of
updates and then some key messages from
me um so first of all in terms of school
testing so as part of the increasing
rates that um
we've seen you know in a couple of areas
in a very small way and we've started to
see further cases in some settings as
part of this the testing team supported
not breaking a school
because it came about on a friday rather
than the usual process of sending a
mobile test unit we were really flexible
in this so we provided a number of home
pcr tests completely instructions on
terms how to use them and as a result we
did find a number of positives that were
asymptomatic which would otherwise would
not have been picked up and could have
led to further spreading when they came
back to school on monday so again just
kind of really positive example of how
testing can help um try and stop that
spread
um another update in terms of our
asymptomatic testing site we've got at
trafford town hall so we've had this
asymptotic testing site now since
january um however over the past few
months we have seen numbers using the
site drop hopefully because people are
becoming ever more comfortable using
home tests so as a result of this we're
going down from five days a week to two
days a week um obviously if demand for
the site increases at any point for
example if plan b was to be brought in
and then we do have the ability and
capacity to go back to five days a week
and obviously everyone can still get
lots of flow tests from usual places
pharmacies libraries or even order
directly to your home
so in terms of those key messages then
as helen said we have seen a reduction
in traffic's testing rate however we are
still the highest um testing rate across
greater manchester and we therefore want
to kind of reinforce that good practice
so if you're anything like me your
weekends now are probably getting taken
up um by by engagements over december so
please please please encourage people to
continue to test twice a week with
lateral flow tests we know they work
because we keep getting positives with
them
um and especially at this time of year
when it's easy to dismiss cover symptoms
of something else um please continue to
get a pcr test even if you have the
maldives of symptoms it's really really
important to remember those key messages
and and just keep up with that with that
good practice
and that's all from me thanks johan okay
thanks for that then very helpful advice
for any questions anybody got
no
okay thanks uh kirsten there's an update
on contract
tracing and outbreak management
yeah thank
so
you
terms of uh schools and complex settings
since returning after the half term
we've had around about 543
cases
reported across our schools and around
about 38 inquiries from the schools
themselves
so activity has reduced significantly
within schools
and
the the skills are managing the new
guidance that came in place in in august
the changes to isolation
and they're really getting on well with
that
we have 30 primary schools that
currently have cases in them
um staggered across different year
groups so we've got four primary schools
that are currently meeting
um the outbreak thresholds of 10 or 5
cases in a classroom
and then we have 13 high schools that
have currently got cases but we have
none of our high schools that are
currently meeting outbreak thresholds so
that's positive in terms of the high
schools
so i've previously explained when a
school is in an outbreak situation would
complete a detailed risk assessment with
them which then could lead on to an
outbreak meeting and we've had um five
risk assessments since returning from
school um since the half term on one
outbreak meeting
and what normally comes from that is
that we will put enhanced measures in
place for a school or a group or a class
and it's um really key that then
measures the the short term usually put
them in place for around about 10 days
and the focus is about keeping children
in school but reducing the risk of
transmission
we continue to run regular q a sessions
with our schools to to support them
across our schools and early years
workforce just to to make sure that we
can support them with that risk of
transmission in schools
and
and in terms of other complex settings
we're seeing a couple of outbreaks in
our care homes and we work really really
closely with them and in almost all
circumstances we have outbreak meetings
with them
um our workplaces and events so we've
got
workplace activity again it seems really
really low at the minute we have around
about 12 workplaces that we're working
and with cases in them but most just
have one case reported we're not seeing
very many outbreaks in workplaces at all
and we continue to monitor the events
such as the manchester united games
and we're still seeing low numbers of
cases in proportion to people that
attend those events
and then finally we have our locally
supported contact racing and so that's
the the cases that the national team
don't manage to reach the positive cases
and that remains um really positive
across trafford so we make sure
successful contact with 80 of those
people through different channels
and we we do full contact racing with
around 70 percent of those
so we're coming currently the third
highest across gm for successful contact
and completion of contact tracing and we
now have that dedicated phone line where
people can call in to us
and
they'll recognize our number as no 161
number
as part of that call and we continue to
support people with self-isolation so we
asked them do they need any support
and we had 66 people supported last week
alone
and
we're getting some really good kind of
outcomes from that support offer now and
and the team are going really above and
beyond to support those people that are
isolating which are kind of having a
wider impact on public health and social
care services
and
so we've got a couple of examples where
one
um
person was
um it was a carer for his elderly next
door neighbor who lives alone and
depended on him for food and education
and our contact traces and the liaise
with the local hub
so that the neighbor got any immediate
food and medication needs the neighbor
was wasn't mobile and so we arranged our
swapping team to go out and for him to
be tested
and the case was very impressed um with
the swift response and obviously the the
need
and reliance of other services
and then we also actually had one who
was hospitalized due to covet
and he was trying to get to the home
country for cancer treatment um but he
was unable to get a negative pcr because
it wasn't meant to test within 90 days
to get that fit to fly
so the team actually went above and
beyond contacted the consulate in london
to see what medical exemptions could
apply they contacted the airline and
actually the team were able to obtain a
medical exemption for that case to fly
on for cancer treatment
and so we're seeing some really good
outcomes from that support on offer as
part of that contact tracing call
and that's it from me
thank you thank you
thanks kirsten is there any questions
anybody would like to ask any
clarification
um
no if not i mean i think those
examples that you gave of the the sort
of the quality and the scope of the
works really helpful so thanks for that
cursor and i think the news about
schools is particularly
pleasing to say the least and it's
thanks to everybody who's been engaged
in
working with schools to to manage
any outbreaks and to bring the rates
down so thank you
we've already had the update from
rebecca and max vaccination so um you
can go to catherine
and community engagement update
thank you morning all and it's a
community engagement update we've begun
implementing our world for winter plan
and that was developed in partnership
with community groups and it's got five
different strands
the first one is health messaging and
calls to actions and making messaging
really clear and tangible and what
people can do to keep themselves and
their families safe
the next strand is working with and
building upon our networks so doing a
lot of work with the community champions
with our volunteers and with the dcfc
sector in general
the third is around uh further promoting
vaccine confidence and understanding
hesitancy and i'll talk a bit more about
what we've done there in a second
the fourth is an events road show so
that's going along to community events
over winter and conducting engagement at
those as well as giving out well-being
packs and leaflets
and then the fifth is around reflecting
with our communities and so we've got a
lot of focus groups across the borough
and to reflect the communities around
the impact of the last year and what
their current needs are
so firstly in terms of the focus groups
um we've now established several of
those and the first one has been hosted
in the west and that was attended by 15
people
and some of the issues that were
highlighted were around recovery from
covid's illness access to gps
and then merging issue around long
covered and helping people to understand
the support that's available so these
are the kind of lessons that we're also
pulling into with the work programmes
and this additional focus groups
scheduled throughout the borough over
winter and all in our four localities
and some of them with specific
communities of interest
so as well as the focus groups
and we're conducting work with public
health um around trying to get deeper
insight on why some people are still not
taking up the vaccination offer and so
what we're doing there is targeting
residents in key demographics and
geographies who've got lower vaccine
uptake who haven't themselves been
vaccinated
we've been trying some different
approaches to this work so so far we've
done street field work where we've had
66 completes come through
we've also had a digital version sent
out by your gp surgeries and those key
areas we've had 83 completes from that
route and today we're also in a gp
practice making phone calls to their
unvaccinated patient list to gain
intelligence by that route as well so
we're taking a multi-pronged approach to
see what works we still need to analyze
all of the responses from that and with
public health but in terms of some of
the initial feedback and we're seeing
respondents report concerns around
vaccine safety we're hearing some of the
conspiracy theories that i think we've
all discussed before you know the
pandemic microchip that kind of thing
and then also interestingly the pure
effect of having a friend group um or a
close contact with strongly
anti-vaccination
that kind of influence upon others i
mean people doing lots and lots of
anti-vaxx research and then sharing that
with their friends or family
um we're also doing a lot of work with
our community champions so we've had um
recent briefing sessions with public
health and we're pulling together an
action plan based on that feedback and
some really useful points there around
how we can better tailor messaging and
how we can make greater use of our
community leaders as well as some points
around how we can push for more
recruitment there and so we're bringing
all that together into an action plan
that we're then implementing
and then in terms of our volunteers more
generally um there was a thank you meal
that was held at limelight on the 3rd of
november and that brought together the
practice team council colleagues
community volunteers and also partners
like the red cross
and to say thank you for their efforts
and going into winter in the new year we
want to make sure that we're holding
similar events or recognition and just
to make sure that we are thanking and
recognising the crucial world wars is
applied in supporting our communities
throughout the pandemic and because
obviously some of those volunteers have
now been
conducting that work for 18 months
and it's so important that we do say
thank you and recognize that work
great then in terms of what we've got
planned so we're pulling together some
options for schools and we're gonna have
a different office which will either be
an assembly for the whole school or
classroom sessions um or holding a focus
group within that school and we'll be
making that offer for schools in areas
where there's greater needs that could
be more cases or lower vaccination
uptake
and then there'll also be a general
offer to all schools which will probably
be around some resources perhaps a video
that they can share in the school
and to answer some of the key questions
that children might have
around things like covered safe
behaviours
and we're also working with our partners
to look at the use of community digital
screens and so that would be providing
digital content
and for various locations in the
community like some of the housing
blocks um or community centres so we're
linking in with our partners there and
to provide that content and plan that
approach with them
and we're also finalizing our winter
assets so we've
got our well-being packs together and
then we'll be delivering those via some
of our events that i've mentioned
previously and also leaving some with
community groups libraries our hubs and
potentially doing some door-to-door
delivery in higher need areas
and that's it for my update if anyone
has any questions
no
thanks for the update uh catherine and
thanks for the um
quality of the work it's really good to
hear about that what you describe as
street level and face-to-face one-to-one
contacts i think that's where we're
really gonna learn you know about
vaccine hesitancy and how to engage with
people so quite a lot of lessons for us
to learn thank you
so the last item is just any any updates
from any board
members anybody
on any activity that's been taking place
no
so
is there any other business i'm assuming
not
um
so thanks everybody thanks for your time
joining the meeting um thanks to the
public health team the community
engagement team
uh the gps and everybody who's working
so hard and so effectively to bring the
rates down and keep everybody safe and
let's hope it carries on
and
see you all in two weeks
thank you george
thank you